Hello everybody. I hope that you are
good. It's been a long time.
I was missing you guys.
But I had some family visiting me from
very far away. It was a long distance.
They had to take a couple of flights.
So,
I wanted to spend time with them. And I
had a lovely week. I hope that you all
did too. But now we're going to go back
to normality. I'm going to be bringing
these daily Bitcoin updates
uh from now on. So, I hope that you
enjoy them. We're going to go now
through the charts, okay? What I see
here is that Bitcoin has moved pretty
nicely. Um to be honest, I've missed
most of this move, okay? During this
move up,
I only took two uh small trades. All
right. So, uh it's a shame, but I'm not
worried because, you know, uh I had a
lovely time. Um I'm sure that in the
next weeks we're going to have lovely
opportunities, too. All right. But what
I can see here,
uh if I remember correctly, we were
saying that we were in this range here.
Okay? So, if we mark it, it would be
something like this.
Okay? We were in this range here.
You had a uh a small deviation here to
the upside. Then uh big deviation to the
downside.
And now you can see the price has
breaking out to the upside.
Okay? Now, the problem with this move,
okay?
First, is that I see a lot of
inefficiencies here.
Check out these liquidity pools over
here, okay? You got some here. Well, not
That one is retraced, actually.
You can see that one is you know,
retraced to the dollar. But it doesn't
matter. You still have some here. That's
one. That's another one. More here.
Um to be honest,
even inside this range, you know, there
are some more of the inefficiencies. So,
that's the first thing that I don't like
about the chart. It seems that we are
overextended, but Bitcoin seems to still
have some momentum to the upside, okay?
So, we're going to go through that in a
minute. Let me remove all of this.
That's better.
Um
more things. If we go into higher time
frame, let's go to the daily time frame.
We can see that here
there is a big we're in a big resistance
zone, okay?
Um I would say that it's this zone over
here.
Okay? Because you can see
that in this zone
you know, this was support, support,
support. Again here, support, support,
support. We come here
support, support, resistance,
resistance. Um now we are again here.
Again here, resistance, and we're back
into this zone.
Okay?
What is this telling me? Well, this is
telling me something very simple, and
it's telling me that if we break above
this zone here
okay? That's above 32,700, then I'm sure
if this can sort of have another run
higher.
Okay?
Now, this is for, you know, swing
traders and higher time frame. We're not
in this zone here
still. So, what we're going to be
planning now is what can we do
until we get here, if we do so, okay?
So, uh that's the first thing that I see
in higher time frame. 32,700-ish.
Break above this zone, and you can have
another lovely
uh run higher. Cuz to be honest, you can
see here some more liquidity pools,
okay?
Check out those three liquidity pools,
and this will take you all the way to
39k.
Uh this one is 35k, and this one is 34k.
So, you could be targeting these levels,
okay? If you can break above 32,000
uh 700-ish.
All right? That's what I see in higher
time frame.
Um let me remove this. Now, if you go
into a smaller time frame
well, into lower time frame. If you go
into the 4-hour time frame
you can see that the 50 EMA is uh
catching up with the current price.
That could be, you know, a nice I would
like to see, to be honest, some kind of
um,
retrace here and test it as a support.
Maybe you can see some correlation some
consolidation and price can continue
higher, okay? But, I think it's quite
important that we test
this 4-hour 50 MA.
I don't know if we will, okay? But,
that's what I'm trying to to say, okay,
for
giving a confirmation that if we have
the support, price can have another run
higher.
Okay?
That's in the 4-hour time frame. Now, in
the 1-hour time frame, you will remember
the Sunday update, okay? What we're
saying that the 1-hour 50 MA could push
price down. That's what it did. Also, we
had here this range. Check the the
orange lines. That's your range high.
That's your range low and that's your
the middle of the range, okay? And we
were saying that if the 1-hour 50 MA
pushed the price down, then we were
going to probably get inside the this
range here, you know, hit the top of the
range
and continue lower. Um, well, to be
honest, the top of the range didn't play
out that well. I mean, it played out
here as a support, sorry.
Again, here as support. But, really,
price didn't really want to come lower,
okay? You can see here. It didn't really
want to
come lower. So, this was the projection
that, um,
I posted on the Sunday update.
Uh, didn't get all the way to the range
close, to be honest. That was, um, my
range close was 29,100 and price went
29,100.
So, that's $100 difference only, okay?
But, it didn't really get there.
It just stayed, if you notice here, look
at these three weeks, okay? They found
support in the middle of the range at
30K. Also, psychological number.
Many orders at 30K, remember?
Um, that's how it usually plays out. So,
now price seems to, you know,
go trying to go to the upside. Um to be
honest,
what I see here
in the shorter term, this is, you know,
talking for today and tomorrow,
it's not looking good for Bitcoin. I'm
going to tell you why. I'm going to tell
you that, you know, if you notice here,
in all this way here,
your resistance was the 50 minute one
hour time frame. Now, if you've noticed,
here it was a um you know, it went above
it, but then it flipped this to a
support. And now we're going to look for
the same, okay? I would like to see
Well, it actually did here, to be
honest. It actually tested as support
already. So,
what it's telling me here that if the
one hour 50 minute MA
keeps being the old support, then we're
going to go, you know, higher to the end
of tomorrow.
Where to?
Well,
um
the first target that I had in mind was
hit. This is liquidity pool over here.
Hold on.
Liquidity pools have to be blue.
Otherwise, they don't play out. All
right. That was the first target, this
liquidity pool. Now, it has created a
new liquidity pool. So, it might again
retrace this whole candle. We'll see
what it does, okay? But to the upside,
you have something pretty interesting,
okay? First, you have this liquidity
pool over here.
Okay? That's at 30,900.
And you also have if you go into the
four hour time frame,
like this one better, because in the
four hour time frame you can see
this liquidity pool here.
This is where I entered my short at 31K.
A short by the way, I posted it to
Twitter yesterday.
Um I took the short because the
liquidation delta was at 40
billions worth of uh long liquidations.
Also, um the volume of this candle uh uh
of this red candle was the same volume
as this green candle. So, that was
telling me that that was pressure to the
downside.
But,
uh I posted yesterday on Twitter that I
booked some profits in this zone here at
30,100, I think it was,
because the delta went back to normal,
okay? All those long liquidations have
been hit in all this way down. So, that
was a reason to take some profits. And
then I set um the stop loss of the rest
of the position
above the 1-hour 50 MA. That was hit in
this candle here. So, right now I'm out
of the position, okay? I'm not in any
position at the moment. Uh I'm going to
try to look for longs. That's what I'm
going to do
uh between today and tomorrow, okay?
It's going to be a small longs
because with all these inefficiencies,
you know, and price is at the highs,
uh I don't like to go long
in here, okay? I don't like to go long
at the highs. Usually, this is what I'm
looking for reversals, if you know how I
trade, because that's what is going to
give you the biggest return. But, it's
true that the trend right now, you know,
it's a still quite a strong.
I don't see the signs of weakness at the
moment. So, it's not telling me
nothing is telling me to go into a swing
short, you know, and target 27K at the
moment. No.
Uh that's why I'm thinking that I'm
going to favor longs
in this um couple of days for two
reasons, okay? The first reason is this
liquidity pool at 31,200.
Um it might get it might get hit.
Also, uh let me change this for you. I
want to see the 1-hour 50 MA.
There you go. Uh because that's our
current support, in my opinion. So, as
long as we are above the 1-hour 50 MA,
then I'm going to favor longs.
Okay?
And my areas are going to be
this liquidity pool here.
And also the liquidity pool that we saw
here in the 1-hour time frame,
that is this one, okay? But, if you go
into the 4-hour time frame,
we have a wick.
All right? So, we're going to favor the
week.
All right? So, uh the 50% of the week is
30,900.
Okay? That's the 50% of the week. So,
that's what we're going to favor, okay?
As long as we are above the 1-hour 50
MA,
then let me remove this cuz we've hit
it.
Then, I'm going to favor,
you know, higher prices towards the 50%
of this week. And if we go higher, then
this liquidity pool at 31,200. And to be
honest, this would be a very nice move.
Cuz imagine if we come again,
you know,
to the 50 MA in the 1-hour timeframe.
Uh this would be a nice
uh 1 and 1/2% or even 2 and 1/2% move,
okay? Now, if you pull, you know, a bit
of leverage, uh imagine times five
leverage, this could be
a 10% profit, okay? Or a 6% profit. So,
that's what I'm going to look for today
and tomorrow. Now, I'm going to go into
Hyblock Capital. Let's see if we can
find something interesting there. We're
in Hyblock Capital in the liquidation
levels. Let's have a look at the delta.
There you go, it's at zero. As I was
saying, back to normality, okay? So,
it's not telling me much. It's not
telling me what position is at risk.
It's not telling me that
if longs or shorts are at a risk, so it
don't tell me much, okay? I cannot
really take much from this. But, what I
can tell from this is that I can see
more spikes of liquidations to the
upside. Check out the right of the
chart, okay?
Uh
I mean, it's quite even, but
I see more liquidity to the upside in
here, okay? And these are high leverage
traders that have gone into shorts
because they're trying to short the top.
All right? Um you can see here at this
level,
that's the closest to the current price,
31,200.
And also here,
you have 31,478.
Of course, uh I've been a bit higher,
but that would be
making new highs. So, for now I'm only
going to be looking at these two because
that's where my liquidity pool is at.
Okay? So,
that's what it's telling me. It's not
telling me much, but if I had to choose,
I think it's telling me that there is
a slightly more liquidity to the upside,
at least for now.
Now, let's go into the heat map.
Let's start with the 12-hour time frame.
Let's see what is going on in this zone.
Okay. You can see a lot of liquidity in
the chart here. To the upside, 30,825
zone, okay? So, you can see in this zone
over here,
there is quite a lot of liquidity.
You see? So,
I think many New York session is going
to be quite interesting because we also
have some liquidity to the upside 31,200
zone.
If I had to choose,
uh I would probably say that it's more
likely that we hit this zone today.
All right. So, I think this New York
session is going to be quite
interesting. I think at least one of
these two zones is going to be hit, or
even both, we'll see. But, I'm favoring
higher prices. Let's go now into the
7-days time frame.
Nothing really going on here.
I mean, again, for this move up, you can
see there's still some liquidity a bit
higher.
Uh we have here a yellow bar at 27,700,
but
uh it seems quite far away from the
current price. So, I'm not going to pay
much attention to it just now.
And then in the 1-month time frame,
again,
liquidity to the to the downside,
24,600,
but remember that high block only adds
liquidations, okay? It doesn't remove
liquidations because they don't know
when,
you know, traders are closing their
positions. So, this liquidity here might
be a bit
misleading, okay? Um I don't know. Do
you really think that guys that had, you
know,
that liquidation
at 24,600
having closed their positions yet.
I'm not sure, okay? I think probably
yes, so I'm not really trusting this
number. That's why you will never see
me,
you know, saying that there is 20
billions
of short liquidations at this level
and from the liquidation heat map
because high block doesn't, you know,
remove liquidity, only adds liquidity.
Uh that's one thing. Now, if you go into
the 3 months time frame,
this chart, I love it. It's very
interesting chart. Let's go there.
You can see that the market maker has
been hitting the liquidity to the upside
non-stop,
right?
Check out this. You have here
all this liquidity to the upside
and they've just, you know, pushed price
up
hitting all these liquidations and it's
still,
you know, there is a lot more liquidity
to the upside because you have here 32K,
but also, of course, when you're at 32K,
there is going to be more liquidity
appearing in these zones. So, it's kind
of like a snowball, isn't it? Um now,
what I'm waiting here is to see,
you know, a shift of momentum. That's
when you can try to jump into showing
shorts.
And at least for now,
you see here a range, but you're not
seeing any weakness for Bitcoin to drop
and go maybe even here at 24K.
You don't have any strong signal that
tells you that Bitcoin is losing
momentum, at least for now. The most
interesting part for me, I would say is
the 12 hours time frame, at least for
today,
because here, you can see some targets
to the upside and to the downside. You
know, so if you start to see Bitcoin
rolling
over from here, then you can expect that
they're going to take this zone, but
until that happens,
we're going to favor higher prices.
We're going to think that 30,800
is the zone that the market maker is
going to take today, okay? To hit all
those
liquidations.
So, this is the chart that I'm going to
keep an eye on for today, okay? As long
as the 1-hour 50 MA, yes, I said 1-hour
50 MA holds at support as it is now, you
know, we that was a resistance,
we flipped resistance into support. We
are right now above the 1-hour 50 MA.
So, as long as that support holds and
we're above it, then we're going to
favor higher prices. We're going to
favor this wick here to get filled at
30,900
and
the second target would be this zone
over here that last style liquidity pool
at the highs of 31,200,
right? That's what we're favoring today
to happen, well, between today and
tomorrow.
Again, as long as we are above the
1-hour 50 MA. If we lose again the
1-hour 50 MA, then, you know,
uh probably we see some sideways here in
this zone here. Maybe it'll make a new
range and some more consolidation, but
as long as we're in the 1-hour 50 MA,
I can't really favor a correction,
right? And I'm telling you, do I think
that these liquidity pools are going to
get retrace sooner or later?
I mean,
probably yes, okay? I would say yes. I
believe they're going to get retrace at
some point, but
for that you need to wait
and find a shift of momentum. And the
momentum right now is still going.
I don't see any weakness in the chart.
But when we see that weakness,
then that's where we can take advantage
of these liquidity pools as targets,
okay? And yeah, again, prices don't go
up
like this in one go. Price, you know,
tends to retrace, then continues higher.
That's how the market moves, okay? If
you go and check the charts,
that's what you see, okay? Check out
this. You think that at this point here
they don't want you were at 24K? People
believe that we're going to go again to
19K? Well, sorry, to yeah, 19,500?
Of course not, but that's how price
moves, okay? Price goes up,
then it retraces, then continues higher,
okay? So, that's what what we're looking
for here, okay?
Price could continue
going higher,
retrace,
then we can see another move higher,
another retrace. Maybe here you see
a shift of the downtrend.
Who knows, okay? But, you can already
jump into swing shorts because you think
that price
is going up.
That's not how the market works, and
that way, if you try to challenge the
trend,
you're going to get burned, all right?
So,
uh that's pretty much everything I want
to say today.
I'm trying to continue posting these two
updates during this week and the
following weeks. Thank you so much for
watching, guys,
and I'll see you soon.